bienvenue à tous ravis de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui paris saclay tv a la
bougeotte
on s'intéresse aux clusters mobilité
transports du futur applications mobiles
le plateau de saclay innove
nous verrons comment le transport du
futur c'est aussi la ligne 18 du grand
paris express dont la concertation se
déroule jusqu'au 12 juin
cette ligne de métro permettra de relier
l'aéroport d'orly au plateau de saclay
en moins d'une demi heure
qu'est-ce que cela va changer pour vous
réponse dans un instant une fois ci le
poids sur la saq la zone d'aménagement
concerté du quartier de l'école
polytechnique à palaiseau les travaux
ont commencé vous pouvez constater nous
y sommes nous feront enfin une étape au
proto 204 ce lieu participative
collaboratif a célébré ses 1 an et un an
d'existence déjà
enfin lyon pas notre agenda ce sera la
fin de cette émission paris saclay c'est
u2 silicon valley à la française une
silicon valley en devenir
gros plan sur le cluster mobilité 27
mille salariés 130 entreprises et ce
défi inventé les transports de demain
nous avons rencontré françois pistre
c'est le directeur de l'institut de la
mobilité durable
renault paristech mais le saviez-vous
les transports du futur se crée déjà sur
vos smartphones
connaissez-vous l'application we hope
non eh bien regardez
la stricte et durable à la mobilité
durable ce n'est pas seulement une
question technologie ce n'est pas
seulement du véhicule électrique versus
du véhicule thermique
c'est un problème sociétal d'abord c'est
un problème de business il faut un
business il faut que le business ne
s'équilibre fauqué business soit
rentable c'est un problème de sources
d'énergie dans le monde où et l'énergie
dans le monde
ou est ce qu'on la trouve et c'est aussi
un problème de technologie
le problème sociétal sur le plateau de
saclay par exemple on va le trouver en
premier vous avez le chalenge campus du
futur os sur le plateau de saclay qui
est une recherche d'idées et
d'innovations pour voir comment rendre
ce plateau modèle en termes de mobilité
durable et finalement toutes les écoles
du plateau de saclay toutes les
entreprises sur ce plateau de saclay se
sont associés pour réussir à trouver un
nouveau modèle
comment développer un nouveau modèle de
mobilité son plateau de saclay et s'est
trouvé comment ce que développer des
véhicules zéro émission partout dans le
monde
on développe une application smartphone
qui s'appelle we hope est en fait j'ai
réinvente l'auto stop et donc on appelle
ça le smart auto stop en fait ça permet
de mettre en relation des piétons qui
sont en train de marcher à rues qui vont
au travail avec les voitures qui leur
passent devant don qu'ils ont simplement
allumer la plaie visualiser les
véhicules qui vont leur passer dans les
prochaines minutes
et si le trajet de ces véhicules des
intéressés ils sont mis en relation
automatiquement ils peuvent rentrer chez
eux comme ça sur le plateau de saclay on
a lancé une grosse expérimentation à
grande échelle sur plus de dix mille
salariés avec cette expérimentation
on a réussi à mettre en relation en
temps réel des gens qui sortaient du
travail qui venait de rater leur bus
avec une des voitures qui leur passaient
devant heikki aller exactement de même
endroit donc ça permet de rajouter une
composante d'une nouvelle mobilité qui
est le smart auto stop
grâce à notre application et qui va
venir se superposer au réseau de bus
existants l'intérêt du territoire de
paris-saclay c'est qu'on retrouve toutes
les plus grandes écoles qui vont se
retrouver ici les plus grands labos qui
vont se retrouver sur le territoire de
paris saclay la dimension qu'il a
finalement de l'étendue du plateau de
saclay
mais la cohérence du plateau de saclay
on va pouvoir mettre en place une série
de systèmes innovants justement et là je
reviens vraiment sur ce challenge le
campus du futur de saclay qui est
vraiment un challenge passionnant sur
lequel on va tout le monde est en train
de réfléchir c'est quoi le
la mobilité durable de demain
restons dans le futur un futur proche
avec la ligne 18 du grand paris express
vous en avez entendu parler évidemment
cette ligne de métro permettra de relier
en moins d'une demi-heure l'aéroport
d'orly au plateau de saclay dès 2024
pourquoi ce projet est une petit
territoire à ses habitants à ses
salariés tout de suite les précisions de
jacques véron directeur du centre cea de
saclay le sénat est présent sur le
plateau de saclay depuis plus de 60 ans
et notre centre de recherche abrite plus
de 7 7 à 8000 personnes tous les jours
qui viennent y travailler du monde
entier donc ce centre de recherche
international a absolument besoin d'un
transport de grande capacité
aujourd'hui on travaille assez
correctement avec la communauté
d'agglomération du plateau de saclay
pour des transports plus locaux le
transport en commun en site propre qui
doit arriver à la fin de l'année déjà
assez moyen intéressant pour autant pour
ramener autant de chercheurs d'étudiants
et d'habitants sur le plateau de saclay
dans le cadre du projet de développement
de ce plateau
ce projet de recherche projets de
développement de r&d avec d'autres
partenaires
il faut absolument un transport de
grande capacité pour ce qui est du
centre de saclay on a d'ailleurs une
gare qui est prévu à proximité de notre
site
nous sommes un bassin d'emploi de plus
de dix mille personnes centre de saclay
mais aussi la petite zone qui était à
côté dans le christ de sacrées et cette
gare est essentiel pour desservir en
particulier notre site
il est d'ailleurs important que
la ligne 18 dans son premier tronçon tel
qu'on le connaît aujourd'hui face
la liaison entre orly l'aéroport d'orly
et le christ de saclay pour aller
récupérer tous les chercheurs et les
scientifiques internationaux qui
arrivent du monde entier pour venir
travailler sur plateau de saclay au cea
mais aussi chez nos autres partenaires
on discute d'ailleurs avec les
partenaires du plateau pour que le
développement de ce plateau et ses
moyens de transport notamment se fasse
de manière la plus efficace possible
nous sommes aussi un gros employeurs du
département de l'essonne et et on a plus
d'un millier de personnes qui habitent
dans les yvelines 2500 personnes en
essonne plus d'un millier dans la ville
de paris donc pour ramener ses salariés
sur le plateau et sur le centre on a
besoin de cette ligne 18
le ca verse tous les ans plus de 4
millions d'euros de taxes transport et
ça depuis plusieurs plusieurs décennies
donc vous voyez un peu l'argent que ça
peut représenter
donc même si c'est un peu terre à terre
on a bien l'intention que les moyens de
transport se développe pour ramener
autant de personnes qu'il est prévue sur
ce plateau de saclay tout le monde
descend à palaiseau cette commune est au
coeur du pôle scientifique et
technologique du plateau de saclay le
quartier de l'école polytechnique est en
pleine mutation avec la création d'une
zac zone d'aménagement concerté objectif
créer un quartier vivant où il fait bon
vivre
pour avoir une idée plus concrète de ces
travaux voici les précisions de simon du
moulin chef de service ville et
transports et celle de nourdine qui
ingénieur agronome génie pur
ce chantier donc on a commencé en fin
d'année dernière
c'est de ce chantier qui est à la phase
1 la phase ii structurantes des travaux
de la zac polytechnique donc l'idée
c'est de viabiliser tous ces terrains
qui étaient plutôt à vocation agricole à
l'origine et donc d'être dans les temps
pour que tous les bâtiments qui vont se
montrer si puisse est alimenté en eau en
énergie en réseau et par ailleurs on
priait on prépare l'avenir c'est à dire
qu'on prépare le cadre dans lequel tous
les futurs lots futurs habitants futures
entreprises qui annoncent installés ici
viendront se raccorder dans le cadre le
plus agréable possible
cette opération est particulière pour
plusieurs raisons d'une part son ampleur
plazac près de 130 hectares deuxième
particularité les habitants puisque on a
l'impression que le paysage est à vide
mais on a des riverains en particulier
qui sont les centres de recherche de
danone des centres de recherche de
thales et nanotechnologies au sud qui
sont extrêmement exigeants qui ont des
problématiques très particulières liées
par exemple à des vibrations à des
mesures qu'ils font et c'est tout un
aspect des travaux qui est assez
spécifique à ce chantier
appelez nous sommes sur le bassin dit
numéro 3 qui constitue un maillon de la
de la chaîne hydraulique de gestion des
eaux de ruissellement et de préservation
contre les inondations
le tableau des vallées par rapport aux
urbanisation qui vont venir sur le
quartier de l'école polytechnique et la
partie écologique environnementale des
projets c'est un chantier qui est des
mariés a maintenant 9 mois avec un frein
travaux prévus pour fin août 15 4
septembre
ces bassins crée donc en périphérie des
milieux qui permettront de reconstituer
des lieux qui ont été détruits par le
projet qui vont l'être pour que le
projet soit le moins impactant possible
des milieux et donc là on sait loin de
la question purement hydraulique pour
s'intéresser à l'autre volet de la
question qui est une question plus
écologique et plus liées à la
préservation telle reconstitution des
milieux qu'on a pour la zac a détruit
aura détruit s'agit de construire un
campus à échelle mondiale envergure
mondiale et donc ça donne une pression
qu'à une émulation collective assez fort
pour réussir ce campus en respectant à
la fois l'environnement déjà existants
et donner la dimension mondiale de ceux
de cette zone
ah non ça se fête le proto 204 à
célébrer comme il se doit son premier
anniversaire
un an d'expérience collective
participative avec plus de 150
événements et 4000 participants
retour sur cette belle soirée avec
stéphanie will cette directrice de
projets externalisés a participé à
l'aventuré
elle nous explique pourquoi j'habite gif
sur yvette et puis il ya un peu plus de
8 ans j'ai créé ma boîte ce dans la
foulée et depuis cette époque j'ai 13
ans veille sur ce qui se passe sur le
plateau de saclay notamment du point de
vue cette grande promesse paris saclay
non j'ai toujours entendu parler et
quand
le proto 204 a ouvert j'ai pensé que
peut-être c'était ma chance c'est la
première fois que quelque chose de
véritables se passe sur le plateau de
saclay qui puisse vraiment faire se
rencontrer tous les publics du plateau
puisque mon expérience du plateau c'est
que on y est très bien mais on y est
d'autant mieux qu'on participe à un
groupe qui est celui des écoles ou celui
des grandes entreprises ou celui du
campus mais ces publics là ne se croise
pas du tout et les habitants qui n'ont
pas de rapport avec le monde
scientifique encore moins donc j'étais
très très en attente en affaires comme
habitante et comme entreprise de trouver
un lieu où enfin je puisse rencontrer
les autres gens du plateau en
s'investissant et en venant
régulièrement la fois comme auditeur des
événements et petit à petit comme acteur
et porteurs de projets soi même et se
passait à ces rencontres extraordinaires
on apprend on découvre on s'enrichit et
on
oui aussi son carnet d adresses j'ai
voulu rendre sa très concret moi-même
monde devenant porteurs de projets sur
du réseautage intelligents au proto 204
non cloisonné où sur un projet qui
s'appelle my bee's in il
j'organise ce qui peut s'apparenter à
des repas d'affaires au proto 204 ou des
pros porteurs de projets salariés
intrapreneurs et puis personnel du
campus peuvent rejoint sur l'heure du
déjeuner 12h 14h au proto un groupe qui
fait de la co création contenu en même
temps qu'il est jeune donc on est sur un
temps obligatoire pour manger et en même
temps c'est à entendre au poète et tente
et on met à profit pour rencontrer les
autres et tous ces autres du plateau qui
sont généralement plutôt cachée plutôt
isolé chacun dans leur branche
donc c'est totalement l'esprit proto se
rencontrer faire
être soi-même dans l'apport de quelque
chose et recevoir des autres et
construire ensemble avant de nous
quitter notre agenda tout ce qu'il ne
faut surtout pas rater dans les semaines
à venir avec déjà cet appel à
candidatures si vous êtes entrepreneurs
innovateurs stark peur et que vous rêvez
de transition énergétique participer au
dream in saclay un événement inédit sur
l'innovation ouverte pour la transition
énergétique
il se tiendra du 23 au 25 juin sur le
plateau de saclay les inscriptions sont
ouvertes jusqu'au 18 juin
c'est déjà la fin de paris saclay tv on
se retrouve très vite
d'ici là restez connectés pour plus
d'information pour plus de précisions
sur toute la qualité de votre territoire
enfin seul site eps.fr merci de nous
avoir suivi et à très bientôt